and this tented City it was hastily set
up by the aid agency here in turkey and
we've spoken to a lot of the people in
the native tongue and they have agreed
to allow us to walk through what is
their community at least for now Nathan
will show you some of the tents that
have been set up these young people
walking with us a little bit of Joy I
think for them but certainly a little
bit of Interest
given what they've had to endure over
the last few days just watch these 10
pegs Nathan as you come through
this gives you an idea of the number of
tents that are here is actually in the
you see at the car park of the museum
here it's an architectural Museum also
damaged during the earthquake but not as
bad as some of the other buildings we
have seen just watch these youngsters
just be careful as we come past Thank
You Salon
and just to show you here it's this is
ice and snow it gives you an idea of
just how cold it's been over the last
few days now uh this is a mahmoud's tent
Mahmoud is from Syria he has 25 people
from his family living in this small
tent when they saw what happened they
decided to immediately flee the home
scene is with me and Zane is going to
interpret for us uh mahmoud's Story
how did you get here foreign
25 of us for several days outside under
the rain under the freezing conditions
and finally we managed to to reach here
as we speak to him is it okay if Nathan
goes inside to see
foreign
we're very thankful for the authorities
Who provided us with some Aid who had
soup for example for breakfast and for
lunch but look we have no electricity we
have no heating we're very cold the
situation is very difficulties
expect there's 25 people in there
that's his daughter
what's her name daddy daddy
oh she's Clinging On Tight there um how
long do they expect to be here for
um
she's not being able to sleep at night
she's crying all the time because of the
cold it's so cold the situation is very
tough it's very hard yeah how long do
they expect to be here come here
we still don't know until the until the
authority so the government tells us to
leave we don't know why did they come
here what made them think immediately to
come here
when we heard that people were coming
here for help and for for shelter we
came here what were the conditions like
at home
no one's left there because we're
terrified of staying there it was you
know total devastation so we can't stay
there it's horrible
no everyone is too scared to go into
apartment blocks into houses that no one
would dare to go in what was the journey
like getting here
we had to walk for about half an hour
they live they live in the city but they
had to walk about half an hour they had
to wait until the aftershocks and the
Tremors stopped and then they managed to
get the family to him okay and finally
um we've had several Tremors already
this morning how are they every time
that happens how do they feel uh
so yeah yesterday at 10 o'clock and at
three o'clock we felt the Tremors and we
were scared
I have five young children myself and I
have all dressed
sleeping on this Fair floor uh with
sub-zero temperatures
this way we are going to be uh spending
our morning here at this refugee camp